pas grave bio tain c'est la caméra
cachée guillotin vous l'attendez tous
les mercredis et tous les jeudis est
avec nous regarde et il a encore fait
très fort ça lui sait gré guillotin
aujourd'hui je me fais passer forains
installés sur une journée de don du sang
pour mettre en place cette caméra cachée
on l'a transformé un local en fout
cabinet médical est sollicité la
complice des internautes qui souhaitent
étudier leurs proches c'est pas c'est à
dire combien de temps votre dernier dont
le sang d'accord vous avez gardé
quelques sourires pour juste pouvoir
orienter si jamais un petit souci c'est
une fois que vous avez une grosse après
qu'il avait pris le sens saint louis par
un temps des deux secondes juste je
vérifiais un petit truc pour la pause
l'infirmière utilisent des tubes sous
vide de type va culinaires et des
églises à des faits il avait basé la
belle stéphanie qu on observe alors ce
dessin caractéristiques il avait une
basilique label céphalique et entre les
deux la veine médiane cubital je repère
saint jacques mais c'est ça aussi la
belle madame je sais pas parce que c'est
phallique et qu une [ __ ]
donc c'est vrai que l'amour médias qui
me taraude sanaa bon c'est ça va je suis
pas ok bon bah je pense que c'est celle
ci à mon avis c'est ça aussi ça m'a tout
l'air 1 je regarde sur le kyoto ça
ressemble elle est où votre vie basée
sur l'anticipation pétrole ça vous
n'êtes pas peur mais je suis pas de voir
ici c'est l'egypte a trouvé ces faux pas
ses mots pas piquer ou raison - parce
que les lui illzach des nerfs est
composé d'un an excusez-moi viol m vous
pouvez venir juste deux petites secondes
s'il vous plaît
la bague pour les nuits email pour les
lycées
[Musique]
attendez je deux petites secondes
tout laisse tomber c'est quoi les clés
du succès ça va je tenterai un reset
relançant la donne et san salvador à le
faire non moi je suis bon moi j'ai pas
excellent merci l'homme dit
ces moustiques ne vous mettez pas parce
que moi aussi j'ai par le sang elles
vont rassurer pas de toute façon au pire
on vous a permis de vous avez mal
pendant deux trois jours et après ça va
ça vient
merci aux données j'avais bien viser et
tirer
oui je comprends la se passe comment ça
c'est angoissant que c'est pareil bout
de métal
non mais ça mais ça je vais donner un
peu d'argent à quelle fréquence on le
fait quand même moi ça me choque et à la
piqûre aussi vous voulez on va
s'arranger je me donne une partie de
l'argent c'est mon métier
donnez la rencontre du sein gérard est
pour l'heure si jamais je sais pas si je
peux la pique et moi toujours je peux
t'en es ce qu'est ce que vous pouvez
faire la piqûre à votre habitat ne
serait pas le faire j'ai vu son cours
progresser votre camps d'étrangers c'est
pas moi je vais vous donner un cachet
[Musique]
ah ah
bon pour cet apport à la rigolade mais
n'oubliez pas que mon chéri en donner
votre sang dans un centre proche et nous
a tout simplement sauvé les séries